et
[Musique]
on est sur le parc à croquant poissy qui
est situé dans le parc du château de
villiers et ce parc a ouvert le 10 août
[Musique]
le parc en lui-même qui est magnifique
les hameçons grande qualité sont en
bonne santé il y avait vraiment un
projet municipal de redynamiser ce parc
est de redonner un petit peu d'élan à
cet endroit qui mérite d'être bien
connue de tous les habitants de
possibles
[Musique]
le parcours filet c'est un parcours
accessible dès 3 ans où on n'a pas
besoin de baudriers pour y accéder on
est en totale liberté mais aussi en
hauteur
les filets sont à une hauteur d'environ
trois mètres du sol et on peut venir
s'amuser en liberté dans la canopée pour
profiter justement de ce paysage de
différentes passerelles et différents
trampoline
[Musique]
on a notamment un saut de tarzan qui est
une activité à sensations fortes
puisqu'il faut se jeter dans le vide
pour atterrir dans un filet un petit peu
plus loin et on a aussi juste au dessus
de moi une tyrolienne qui fait plus de
cent mètres à travers la forêt et le
parc du château de villiers les
obstacles sont assez sont assez
classiques l'idée c'est d'être
accessible à l'ensemble des familles et
donc pas forcément trop difficile
physiquement on retrouve les ponts de
singe on retrouve les ponts en croit les
fameuses tyrolienne qui sont toujours
des valeurs sûres en accro branches mais
aussi quelques activités un peu plus
difficiles notamment les filets
suspendus ou ou les anneaux
[Musique]